[Music]
good morning
today is a brand new day and i'm very
excited because
i am going to be tackling my desk yes
i am going to tackle your desk how am i
going to tackle my desk you asked
i'm going to be repainting it all and
i'm going to be recycling the paint the
leftover paint that we had from the big
mood set
so that green i was obsessed with that
green so i'm like listen can i just take
the rest
of this paint because i need to use it
somewhere somehow and i decided to paint
it
or to use that paint for my desk and i
also bought this contact paper
to recover the top of the desk and
i purchased new hardware for like the
the drawer pulls and the drawer knobs
then i'm gonna have a completely new
desk
so let me go show you this beast of a
desk it's not even a beast
it's a it's actually a really small desk
it's so small that i was actually
considering
buying a whole new desk because the
surface
of this desk is significantly smaller
than casey's for example so look check
this out
this from here to here it's about 16
inches
compared to casey's desk which is 29
inches so it goes like
way further out and you know how i was
saying that i was planning on using this
desk for like a vanity slash
my office desk probably not going to use
it as a vanity
i'm probably only going to be using it
as an office desk
and i'm just going to continue to do my
makeup in the bathroom
like i'm supposed to so that's my plan
for this desk
but yeah so as you can see i already
have
contact paper so i i put this contact
paper
on here back when i bought this desk for
the office the jk office and then i
actually
painted these gold like i spray painted
these but i
took one off already since i purchased
the new guys
here they are i got these gold
pulls for these and then
these gold knobs for these
and i'm just going to be painting all of
this this green over here
have it saved right there this outside
paper
is in here and it's i thought it was
kind of weird that they wrapped it
the other way because you can't see the
design but it's it's like a marbleish
design because
all contact paper that is out right now
or most of it
that is remotely cute is kind of like
this
it's like this weird or i don't know if
it's weird but this like marble
design but this time i got one that was
like slightly pink i think it was
i don't remember anymore because i
bought this like last week
i'm gonna park it right here and then
i'm gonna open the garage door
and i'm gonna get the painting i'm not
gonna prep it i'm not gonna sand it i'm
not gonna prime it and i'm just gonna
paint the green over this white
hopefully it comes out looking good
[Music]
alright so i just finished removing
the contact paper here it is this is
actually really easy to remove
i mean it was hard to pull it off but
meaning
easy on the actual material here except
for this tiny little part where the
paint
actually bubbled up so i gotta figure
out how to fix
this or maybe it's not a big deal
because i'm gonna be covering it with
more contact paper
i don't know what do you think so check
out all the drawers
i'm gonna start painting here
and then i realized i totally forgot to
buy a brush but luckily i had this brush
because i bought a stencil kit so i can
do
the outside flooring which i still have
to do it's like
a project a beast of a project that i
haven't tackled on yet
um but yeah it came in this tiny little
this cutest
little tray with paint um but luckily
i had at least this brush so i'm gonna
be just using this brush for this entire
desk
so it's going to be very very laborious
but
we'll get through it hopefully i have
enough paint that's the only thing i'm
really concerned about because
i just don't know if i have enough paint
if i run out of paint at least i know
what color it is i could go
run to home depot really quick and get
some more paint but i'm hoping i don't
have to do that
so wish me luck
[Music]
[Applause]
all right before i start painting though
i
decided to secure this entire back
piece with my staple gun so you can see
the new staples
i tried hammering in like the old ones
because they're pretty
they're sticking out but it's not a big
deal this is going to be put up against
the wall anyway
no one's gonna see it but i did want to
secure it because every time
i would touch this it'd be like really
rattly but now
that it's nice and secure it's sturdy
okay now i'm gonna open the paint
[Music]
i didn't use a brush i ended up using
this tiny little foam roller that
i bought for my stenciling project
but i have extra rollers so i was like
ah it's okay
i could use it for this so i did and it
did make my
life a lot easier i should have done
something to the paint
because it was really hard to get that
first coat
in that like the paint kept moving it
was really hard but the second coat
wasn't that bad i'm still not done i had
to take a break because
in the middle of me doing this i
realized i had an orthodontist
appointment so i went to my ortho
and today was supposed to be the last
day that i have my invisalign but
we decided to keep going because there's
some
stuff that we still need to tweak and so
now i have to wait for my new aligners
and that's gonna take about six weeks so
not until the new year am i gonna get
my new liners so these are gonna start
getting ugly and yellow and gross
so this is what it looks like now this
is the second coat
it looks pretty good actually there's
like maybe a few places
i can go over again and
this is the second coat but here is when
i had to leave
oh no oh no
oh no what do you think i should wear
white or black oh you're talking about
your new shoes
yeah they look tight i was wondering
whose shoes they were yeah so
jk news got sponsored by this company
called
vessi and they are like completely
waterproof
shoes and then joe was like hey does
isaac wear
size eight shoes because i think they
don't fit him or i forgot what it was i
don't remember
what the reason was i don't remember i
think i think they
do or i don't know maybe they were too
small
yeah so then isaac fits them perfectly
and now he has to have these all white
ones or those black and white ones
anything i should wear probably the
black ones because you're gonna go use
your hoverboard huh
this tree yeah keep the white ones white
for like
events or like i guess there's no events
right now in the pandemic but like or
just for things
yeah he's quickly gonna grow out of
these like
swears he's gonna grow out of these so
fast before he can really truly rock
them these are really cool though
because like
other than the top part of the shoe like
the entire shoe is completely waterproof
you're getting a pair i won't yeah like
i like the way they look i've just been
seeing them like on the ground over
there like who shoot
yeah and then look i was able to get a
pair too and i got these pink ones but
the thing is that they're kind of
tight because of the fact that they're
no no like up here
because they're supposed to be like
really waterproof like around my ankle
and i have a really skinny ankle but but
it's like
really tight on my ankle so that's one
thing i don't like about them but other
than that these shoes are really
comfortable
it sounds like a brand deal we didn't
get sponsored but
we always talked about all the birds too
like when we got all birds we like loved
them so much that i think in a couple of
vlogs in the past we like
i know like it was a brand new i know
literally look at look at my shoe
my shoe closet thingy here it's a mess
but look
all birds all birds all birds all birds
casey's auburn
birds all birds
and then isaac's been wanting a pair too
but luckily joe came through
and got him some fake all birds i don't
know
they're not all birds but they kind of
look like them they're comfy
they're nice nice all right see ya
you should ride your bike dude get some
exercise all he does is just stand
anyway back to the desktop this is the
first coat so you see how it was
quite difficult to really get the paint
to stick
anyway i'm about to do the second coat
because now i'm home and now i can do it
and i'm intentionally
not painting the top because i'm gonna
cover it with contact paper anyway and
then also i didn't want i don't know how
thick the contact paper will be so i
don't want the green to affect
the contact paper in any way like what
if it darkens it or something so i left
the top white on purpose
and then after that i have to i have to
paint
every single drawer especially these
because it has
that design from from the old handle
thingies
but i gotta paint those and i have to
line these
then put all the new hardware that i got
and then i'll be done with my desk oh no
wait and i have to cover the contact
paper and then i'll be done with my desk
and i get to
enjoy it upstairs because that like spot
where it belongs it's been kind of like
empty and i'm like every time i sit
there i'm like my desk should be
right there
[Music]
all right i am finally 100
completely done with the painting i've
already done
two coats on everything the drawers the
entire desk
and all of that good stuff okay got all
the painting done i was about to start
on the contact paper
but i accidentally
did not properly measure the length of
the contact paper
so this is what we got so you know how i
said that this is 16 inches
so i ended up ordering like a 17 inch
long
wallpaper but apparently or not
wallpaper what is this contact paper
technically this is like 16 and a half
so i guess 17 is like way too on the
nose
for the for just the surface but i
wanted to like bend over
the entire counter top so in order to do
that i need to order a longer one
because when i ended up trying to to
work around it and be like okay well
maybe i can just have the entire contact
paper on
the surface and then have the other
like the excess contact paper cover the
rest of it but
it turns out i don't have enough so i
just ordered some more contact paper and
the proper length so
not until that comes in am i gonna be
able to do this but check it out though
do you guys like it i don't know if the
camera can
properly show you the the color but
it is it's kind of like old
like a little bit of gold on here i
don't know if you guys can see that but
it's a little bit gold it's like a matte
finish so compared to the other contact
paper that i had that was like a really
glossy finish so
i really like the matte finish so it was
listed as
waterproof so we'll see about that
i think it is though it's like really
thick so it's a pretty
pretty nice quality contact paper here
now i just gotta wait
for the right size to come in since i do
have this contact paper
i actually want to see if i can make
this fit
in our entryway because there's like
this like entryway thingy
the paint that the house came in is
really sticky
so every time we put something on there
it's like super super sticky
here's the place that i'm talking about
this can this can probably work
but yeah i don't really like this the
paint that they ended up
finishing this as so i think i'm just
gonna cover this space
with this contact paper that i have at
least i'll put it to you
somehow it's not a complete waste of a
purchase originally when we first moved
in
well after we moved in actually because
we went to visit a neighbor
and a neighbor had paid extra he got his
own contractor guy
to do this part this like banister thing
as like the exact same countertop as his
kitchen countertop
so i'm like oh that's genius we should
probably try to do that and that was
like one of the ideas that we were like
oh we should do that to the house but we
just never got around to do it
and i mean it's not like crazy
necessary for like a legit countertop
might as well
just cheat it and make it cheaper with
contact paper that's the plan that's
what we're gonna do
we'll see how that goes and as for the
desk
right now i'm gonna try to see if this
is dry enough i think it is
i think it's pretty dry and i'm gonna
see what the actual pulls and
knobs thingies that i got look like on
it
once again i did not measure properly
and these beautiful
beautiful poles
don't fit so my done ass
did not measure properly like this is
really off like how did i measure
so wrong i ended up getting three and
three quarters
when in reality it's two and a half
i am so annoyed with myself but anyway
these look great these came out really
good
but unfortunately now i'm gonna have to
look for
other ones and if i remember correctly
they did not have two and a half
for these specific ones so
i'm gonna have to find a different pull
that matches these knobs because these
are really
cute but whatever let's look at the
positives here look how sexy this looks
and then just picture that contact paper
up here actually i have a piece
here look at this this looks good
i can't wait till it's completely done
and i have it up in the office
i am so annoyed at myself right now and
then also
i'm so annoyed because well okay not
super annoyed because i knew what i was
doing but
i should have sanded this down
because now you can see the entire
outline from the old
poles and that's definitely going to bug
me
but it's not going to bug me enough
where i need to sand it and paint it all
over again
it's it's i can live with this i can
live with that okay we're gonna fix it
we're gonna fix it we're gonna get what
we want okay
and then we're all gonna be happy yes
yes
all right so this is what it looks like
now with all the drawers
put in and i decided
to just leave these guys i was talking
to jess
and i was telling her about my whole
whole dilemma and how
i wasn't able to get the correct size
and i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna put these in temporarily until i
find the poles that i actually want and
she was like why they look cute
like it has like a romantic feel so
i was like yeah but i really don't like
how like
how loud this is so
i'm not a fan of that and she was like
well you're not gonna be slamming it
you're not gonna be hearing that sound
all the time and i'm like yeah i guess
you're right
so she kind of convinced me to chill out
on the search for
the other pools that i really wanted and
just
live with these for a while i mean it
does look cute anyway
i don't know what do you guys think
should i keep these
older pools or should i keep on the
search
for a modern poll to kind of match with
what i already purchased here or do you
guys think it's like a nice compliment
like the modern
and old like more traditional style let
me know in the comments
what do you guys think but in the
meantime this is what i'm working with
and
not until the other contact paper will
it be
100 complete but here we go tomorrow
morning we will be moving it into the
office
and we'll see how it looks there all
right
check it out this is what it looks like
in
the office now we just need to
finish the countertop and i have to look
for a computer
chair because it's going to be very
uncomfortable for me to sit
only on the stool the whole time what do
you think i love it
yeah makes my desk look not comparable
to yours
no i think it matches really well like i
think they complement each other
like like from my perspective in this
corner they're looking that way i'm like
your desk to like that lamp this all
looks
so good yeah well ignore those blankets
that is actually gonna get hung up here
which by the way shout outs to
beau uh fanglin i think is how you say
his name he actually
sent me this from germany and oh my gosh
i've had it for so long and i
finally finally purchased a frame for it
and i cannot wait until it goes right
there
it's going to be pretty cool and then
also i'm going to be hanging these
things up
this one i got many years ago this is
kind of like throwing it off
but i don't know i feel like it can go
here
it works your unicorn you can make
anything thanks
but then i was also thinking we could
make like an entire gallery wall here
and then we can like build a part of it
we should definitely get in contact with
them and do like a family portrait or
something maybe
put more artwork up i could ask but his
thing is mainly doing girls
but so like that's his style he usually
does he does like style
stylized girls but i could ask and then
also i'm gonna put
these guys up somewhere i don't know
where
like maybe it's too cramped there i have
no idea maybe i could frame up the
window
we'll see what happens
like i love the the blinds oh yeah it
looks so pretty
i know looks great i did a good job in
this room
you did yay you like it yes i love it
[Music]
but check out what i did last night look
i ended up cutting a piece right and
right here is where i could
i connected it but if i didn't tell you
you would have never
noticed would you there was this little
patch here
that i was gonna just leave it white but
then casey's like nah you should do it
you know it's gonna bug you and i'm like
dang it
you're right you know me so well so i
ended up doing this too not
bad not bad at all let me know what you
guys think
[Music]